All right. It's time for Hatra at Mail Hydroxy.
Chloroquine playing a big role in hatred.
Male this week, both in our new introduction
as well as today's hatred mail itself. Quick
reminder, what is hatred?
Male Why don't you take some hydroxyl chloroquine
for that Trump Derangement Syndrome?
Teary eyed man written by patriots who hey
David Pakman because America and because freedom.
All right. So this week's Patriot Mail is
particularly unhinged and it actually relates
to some of the stories that we've got coming
up next. Let's take a listen to it together.
As I like to say, wow, PAC Man is one who
watches this crap. Obama showed the world
what a pantywaist we can be. You're worse
than the young turds. My God. Twenty twenty.
Packman is evidence of what happines when
the vegan diet is soy boy. I was disgusted
when David Pakman pretended to believe accusers.
You want to help build a genocide genius gate?
Sell his anti-virus injections? Fine. But
let us have our clauer Quinn.
Yeah. So you may have noticed that we don't
hear Donald Trump mentioning chloroquine anymore
unless someone forces him to talk about it.
Fox News is barely talking about it anymore.
Although they did do one segment about it
this morning, which I will be playing for
you later. And it's because there are more
and more studies showing not only that it
doesn't appear to be particularly efficacious,
but it may actually increase death rates.
Very, very scary stuff. And we will follow
up about how this has been propagandized around
now for for a full month or maybe even five
weeks. We will discuss shortly. Remember,
the best way to fight hatred it's in your
community is to use the coupon code, Hatra
at 40. Whenever you sign up for a membership
at join Packman dot com, that coupon code
saves you 40 percent. The Hatra, it's hate
it. It's HKT r i o t for zero.